this season of sex ed is brought to you
by lilo
stick around until after the episode to
learn a little bit more
did you tell your parent when you lost
your virginity
no i didn't i don't think so that's kind
of awkward did you tell your parent
i told my parent i was pregnant so i
think she figured it out from there
[Music]
so i'm going to just read out some
questions to you guys
you'll write down your answers
okay this is exciting this is like class
let's see how many people do you think
the other person has slept with
oh i don't even know
was this accurate very close like up or
down
close your number's way too high
it is you think it's but it's
you've been alive a long time yeah
what's yours
let's see seven
and he said 28.
[Laughter]
what is an appropriate means to lose
your virginity
16 huh i was okay with 16.
16 billion i mean it's reality
what yeah did you lose your virginity oh
gosh
sorry i know
what what could she do that
you won't tell me 15.
yeah what man
[Laughter]
how cute
have you ever caught the other having
sex um
yeah you've caught me having sex i have
oh
one time it was six in the morning i'm
like why are you even doing anything at
six in the morning
because at some point you just don't
care maybe like one time i was like
that sounds a little odd coming from the
other room but it wasn't like a cot
thing
yes you what are you talking about who
would i be talking it's about each other
yeah you're you're moaning pretty loud
don't say that
it's just the truth are you making this
up i swear
you're making it yes you are i'm not i
left
i went down to the garage there oh
did you tell your parents when you lost
your virginity
no wow i don't
i didn't think it was i'm supposed to
tell you guys i was like
i i kind of probably i didn't want to
know uh
no i didn't yes you did i did yeah in
hawaii
oh my gosh yay that wasn't that wasn't
it
no i did um
and it's kind of funny because i it's
the fact that i said it so casually that
i just showed it to her work
and we're in the middle of conversation
i'm just like oh yeah we snuck into the
house and had sex
and that's how she found out and she's
just like okay great now i get to have
this big conversation while i'm at work
thanks
so what happened for me was we went to
the doctor's office was it
senior year like 17 or so yes i went to
the doctor's office and they obviously
asked about it because on that i was
that age you know
and i was like mom don't look at this
question there because
just don't look at it and so obviously
she got the hints and then uh
so that's how she found out are you
uncomfortable talking about this
yes yes i am
i'm not i'm not
awkward i had no problem like i said
with your sister's not with you i just
why do i just feel uncomfortable to a
certain extent
yeah that's all right next to a certain
extent it's an open
conversation in our home but not
personal
experiences yeah not details no that's
weird
no i'm not at all uncomfortable about
talking about sex i think it's something
natural
that needs to be talked about a lot of
us in the youth now growing up have
fallen into learning about everything on
our phones
learning about everything through a
video that in itself can cause a lot of
traumas
when you're not having that real engaged
conversation with your parent
who gave birth to you but they're
learning this in the video
well i'd rather them hear if we could be
that sign
to hey when you're done watching this
turn off your phone turn off your
computer
and pick a serious conversation to have
with your parents yeah because if we
learn
everything on ourselves we have no idea
how we're gonna handle every single
trauma we go through
have you ever told your son about the
night he was conceived
am i an accident
[Music]
i don't know which night it was it was a
noobsy
yeah wow all right yeah you guys are
just going crazy or
yes my parents liked uh going to the
drive-ins
um they like going to drive-ins and
watching a certain movie i don't know
what the name of the movie is
but um they never watched the movie they
couldn't tell what the movie's about
so do you worry about your son getting a
girl pregnant
oh my god every every 24 hours
yes you think i'm like so like no
i just that's why i'm like yeah not
anymore
i did and when he was in college we
would
venmo him money and say buy a box of
condoms
don't be dumb there's no excuse
absolutely
i ask him i ask you regularly if you're
wearing protection and yeah he's been
off you've been honest and told me when
you haven't
yeah and that spikes up my anxiety a bit
i did worry a lot about you guys having
children
young i had you at 18. so i certainly
did not want
that for you what kind of contraception
if any does the other person use
well you're a condom user yes
i've seen them in your room yes oh yeah
yeah do you still even have some of
course we do
we're human the bulldog game yeah
you don't use the card you send my money
back to him
i'll be honest i don't really know what
contraception means
are you serious yeah i don't know it's
just going over my head i don't know
protection trojans condoms yeah i use
trojans
okay do you use any conscious condoms
and i have an iud
do you know what a bag is it's like it's
like
is that the uterus is that what that no
it's like
yeah you know tesla you know the tesla
like symbol no
it's like the little thing you just they
put it up into your uterus and it just
kind of opens and it
stays inside you you should learn you
should learn
i should have done my research about
this stuff
did you teach your son about consent
yes especially in college um
i was like even if they're drinking like
just be careful because a yes could
really mean no
and just like you really want the person
to be conscious when they're agreeing to
it i think we had a huge conversation
i think i've i've said the term no means
no
but that's about it i think you would
know your own son better than to say hey
this guy seems like he needs a little
talk about consent
no i think it's important i think it's
important to to
teach that and i think i think i think
both ways i think for girls too
so i apologize for not giving you that
talk yes we definitely did
um a lot of times when there is a
situation
it's harder to prove your word it's your
word against their word
and we did not want them to be in
a position where they would even be
questioned
and have their whole career and their
life put in jeopardy
once you are labeled a sex offender or
anything that your life is
there's no quality of life after that
how did your parents teach you about sex
in what ways do you wish it was
different
it's just like a a weird subject but
they they
help me like not see it as like so
like uncomfortable i would say what did
you wish you could have seen different
i don't know i feel like you guys did a
really good job the only thing i would
say
i'd change is maybe uh you know
both of you guys sitting down at the
same time talking about it because you
can get like a perspective from both
my parents didn't talk to me about sex
just
went to the high school dance and said
don't dance too close to the boys
i swear to god that's what your bella
said
never really that was it that was it
extent of it well now we know where that
came
yeah yeah do you wish that that was a
conversation
oh yeah i did i did but i you know we
would hear stuff at school and we took
sex
ed and we had you know friends and i
mean
we didn't have the i didn't have the
internet i couldn't google anything so
it was just everything was from
everybody's experiences that they had it
was treated
as if it were a dirty secret
they did what they were comfortable with
and what they knew for that
time period and i understand but like my
mother told me if you don't like the way
we did something change it
and i did what's something you would
like your sons
or other young men to know about sex
education
whatever the sexual encounter is but
being respectful
and and considerate that it is not all
games
that there is emotion behind the
the whole act of sex and it's more than
just a physical thing
they learn from porn they learn from
whatever media
media forms that teach it and i really
wish that there was more
education out there about really how to
connect
when i became sexually active i think
that i put more emotion
into it so therefore i was kind of
giving myself and i felt like i was
giving
love so i think that's important that
it's not just about this physical act
there's an emotional aspect to it too um
that we need to be aware of yeah that
would be most important
it's like the first one that stands out
to you probably this one
because it's the one i would use if i
was a dude
this would be tight i think this is a
dildo it's pretty strong
you can hear that you can hear that one
though
the thing that i like about vibrators is
trying to figure out what end goes where
the bigger side goes in nice that makes
sense sex 101 let's go
so this is the hugo hugo offers double
stimulation one for your prostate and
one for your perineum
opening up endless pleasurable
possibilities this
is the f1s v2 lilo decided to tackle the
stigma
surrounding men and the use of sex toys
there are
four customizable programs and a mobile
app so you can personalize your
experience
i think i touch them a little too much
and come off like a real freak i love it
part of my like discomfort right now is
my awareness that my parents are gonna
see this later
we didn't really talk about sex now that
i'm an adult we talk about it openly
especially like
i'm gay and in a homosexual relationship
so my parents are surprisingly very
comfortable asking me questions or
talking about my relationship
and i think that is super impactful and
powerful for teens and
people you know starting to explore
their sexuality
i don't know exactly where my prostate
and perennium are
i'm not super familiar i'm a virgin
what a great day
beautiful brandon
[Music]
you